que je regrette c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement n'a pas mis l'été à profit
pour tout préparer en cette rentrée
je ne sais pas vous mais moi je n'y
comprends rien vous trouvez que le
gouvernement a mal géré cette crise
sanitaire bas j'y comprends rien moi je
pense que je suis comme tous les
français il ya quinze jours on nous dit
que tout va bien et à 48 heures le
président de la république dit attention
il va falloir sans céder à la panique
prendre un certain nombre de nouvelles
mesures nous annoncer un ségur de la
santé pour soutenir enfin nos médecins
nos infirmiers nozette soignants
réorganiser le système de l'hôpital et
des cliniques dans notre pays
réformer le système très technocratique
des agences régionales de santé
je n'ai rien vu en tout cas dans notre
région de très concret je ne comprends
rien sur les tests puis ce que j'entends
et c'est bien naturel il faut se tester
mais les résultats mettent parfois
quelques heures quelques jours
j'entendais même certains en sologne qui
attendent 7 8 10 jours pour avoir les
les résultats le principe de la 14ème
qui était donc de 14 jours est en train
de basculer à sept jours
le chômage partiel femmes en bref c'est
très flou et qu'il manque un capitaine
qui annonce très clairement un
calendrier des mesures et qui dit en
toute transparence à vérité-là besoin
par liane mais vous croyez qu'il ya que
les français en ont pas marre ça fait
des décennies qu'on annonce des plans 10
milliards 50 milliards 100 milliards
c'est l'argent de qui d'abord c'est
l'argent des fours des français c'est
l'argent des contribuables et légendes
l'europe également exactement et donc
des contribuables parce que le budget
européen est alimenté par les
contribuables français et européen est
donc la seule condition mode je demande
c'est que ça reparte du terrain et que
ce soit très concret je vais vous
prendre un exemple une valeur
fondamentale du développement économique
fondé sur l'écologie les verts d'extrême
gauche qui porte une idéologie que je
considérais que nous considérons comme
dangereuse ce sont les verts d'extrême
gauche qui compare la police à vichy ce
sont les verts d'extrême gauche qui
tolèrent qu'on puisse kuaté des
appartements privés au de manière
légitime parce que ces gens vont mal
c'était les propos de la l'adjointe à la
mairie de paris
europe ecologie les verts hier chez
vos confrères d'une chaîne de télévision
ce sont les verts d'extrême gauche qui
propose à terme l'interdiction de la
voiture à bordeaux de la chasse disait
monsieur jadot il ya quelques jours de
la pêche peut être un jour de toutes nos
traditions
le maire de bordeaux qui il ya quelques
heures avant cela vole noël se supprimer
les sapins de noël au nom du charte du
droit des arbres on nage en plein délire
ça suffit face à cette idéologie
dangereuse
moi je souhaite fédérer tous ceux partis
du bon sens tous ces élus de droite bien
sûr mais bien au delà on voit even
quelques heures à siran utérin défendre
d'autres traditions défend des valeurs
du travail de l'ordre d'une écologie on
va au puley raid une vraie qualité
longueuil ni monsieur macron ni madame
le pen ne portent les valeurs
essentielles du travail
moi j'entends toute la journée les
français qui me disaient ils ont raison
qu'il n'ya plus d'écart entre les
revenus du travail et leurs revenus de
l'assistance nous sommes nous le parti
le mouvement du bon sens qu'ils
souhaitent recréer un écart entre les
revenus de l'assistance et le revenu du
travail en augmentant les salaires en
baissant les charges d emblée tout le
monde en parle dans ses ressorts de la
fae mans mais nous nous faisons de la
sécurité qui est là faire de tout le
monde comme les au logis qui est
aujourd'hui très à la mode aujourd'hui
on peut plus faire de politique d en
parler d'écologie vous dire moi je crois
pas au blabla je crois pas la politique
du tweet de monsieur macron des verts ou
de quelques autres qui m'intéresse c'est
le concret madame le pen et les français
en sont très conscients elle comme tous
les extrêmes ont démontré leur
incapacité à trouver des solutions
madame le pen monsieur mélenchon de
temps en temps sur des sujets peuvent
porter ou poser des constats juste sur
la société française
mais jamais et je le dis à nos
compatriotes jamais les extrêmes n'ont
été ne sont et ne seront en capacité de
fédérer les français de rassembler au
delà des étiquettes et de porter un
nouveau souffle avec des mesures très
concrètes très crédible moi ma fierté en
tant que
numéro deux des républicains élu député
de la nation élus du monde rural
c'est au quotidien d'essayer de trouver
une solution concrète à un problème